some American cities have bosses some
use trams and trains and there's one
that uses golf carts my name is Vanessa
Fleisch and I am the mayor of Peachtree
City Georgia it's a small city of about
35,000 people that is about 20 minutes
south of Atlanta
it's asphalt paths we have over a
hundred miles of them they range from 8
feet to 10 feet wide in some places if
they're used for golf carts mostly we
have over eleven thousand registered
golf carts in the city and obviously
pedestrians bicyclists all kinds of
traffic is on these paths mornin and you
do have to register them yes you do um
the people in the city do register them
there's someone else approaching is now
I'm assuming yes it's like regular roads
you pass on the right - correct yeah yes
it's a parallel road network basically
the majority of the city is accessible
by carts and that's a huge attraction
because parents can pick up their kids
at school if they want to and some of
the kids can drive themselves yes so the
younger kids are the sophomores at the
local high schools are allowed with
their learner's permit to drive their
carts to school Wow it's a bit of
freedom that they enjoy and I guess if
it's limited to 20 miles now there's
less of a chance of a bad bump so this
is the high school this is there's
parking at the high school for 615 parts
that is a lot of golf carts do all the
students leave at once here is it is it
just a traffic oh it is it is a traffic
jam of golf carts and it's not always
pretty I'm gonna have a limiter they do
it sometimes they can be removed and
they go faster than they should and
which is good no that's exactly what I'd
have done it like aged 15 with my own
golf cart I would have removed the
limiter on some of the cards have
heaters inside them along radios you can
soup them up as much as you want
really after they saw the popularity in
the 70s what they did was they required
whenever there was a new subdivision of
houses built that they connect to the
paths for the most part the car paths
are laid out at the same time they lay
out the roads so what all the road rules
here it's not even a regular vehicle
you've just got more practice you can go
on yes and there is no path you are
allowed to be on the road but that's why
we've expanded the past because we're
trying to keep people off of them as
much as possible sometimes people who
have never been here have been caught on
part paths but their car is thinking
that that's the right thing to do
I wanted it take you through a
drive-thru so it appears McDonald's I'm
still kind of getting over the fact that
I'm gonna drive through in a golf cart
thank you should point out not not
sponsored this is not probably specific
the brakes on this are very good I'm
sorry it's like very abrupt on better
than the alternative Peachtree City was
a planned community correct so how did
it go from we're gonna build some houses
here to we're gonna have something that
I don't think any other city in America
has got started originally as a lake
kind of retreat for Atlanta residents
and the people who were here basically
on only on the weekends they started
taking their golf carts on the roads
leaving playing golf this whole separate
Network came up as a result of that to
get them off the roads on their way home
so this was found in the 1950s 1959 by
Joel Cowan he was a college student when
he designed and founded this city Wow
it's very quiet
see what I mean good great
along here this is Lake Peachtree sorry
I got distracted by dogs
that's the founder mr. Cowen and his
cousin were the ones that put up the dam
in spillway originally that made this
lake 100,000 gallons a second it goes
over this people do pay taxes to pay
towards these rooms and process 1.8
million dollars a year to maintain what
we have as well as the 29 bridges and 29
tunnels this is a pretty affluent City
which I guess is one of the reasons that
the golf cart paths work but there are a
lot of cities like that in America and I
don't I'm trying to work out why it's
worked here and it hasn't elsewhere most
mirrors when they when they see or hear
about us and they think oh we can do
that well you know they've got older
cities right so they they really can't
only as part of it is common is that you
need a huge amount of upkeep in tax
temple to to make this work right but
it's also because you need to set the
whole thing up or it doesn't work you
can't have a quarter of a car network
because no one will buy a cardinal and
use it you need to connect with
everything or it's not worth it
right thank you very much thank you you
find it more about Peachtree City in the
links in the description
as roses no seatbelts on this